[Music]
all right
foreign yeah
[Music]
all right
okay
[Music]
oh
55 zone
if you have your license registration
fight house high and then you can either
go to court or do it online
[Music]
over here on medical are you okay
please
[Music]
fuck
yeah we contacted this guy earlier he
failed to stop for us at the booth he's
now at the visitor center
uh looks like a middle parking lot i'm
gonna block it man
visitor center on the parking lot you're
gonna block him in metro and nhp is that
with you
get your hands out
get your heads off now
[Applause]
stop i'll
shoot stop or i'll shoot
put your hands down now
put your hands on them
get on the car
get out of the car
[Music]
get out of the car now
get out of the car
55 44 he's just rambling
[Music]
he ram your vehicle in a range
i hear noise he's trying to get out
you hear something
right behind you okay
he's trying to start it
stop the cards
no visual
let me get right here
stop the car 55-44 shots fired
get out of the car get out
get out
get out of the car
put your hands up get your shield get
your shield get up no come with me come
in this way we're gonna let's go keep
your hands like this keep your hands
just like that
okay your hands are got it
you you did an assault rifle
okay just keep your hands or you can see
him just keep him just like that just
like that shot me in the middle okay
slow down slow down bro
we're going to get you okay i'm here to
get you
i'm here to get you
you're gonna come towards me okay you're
gonna come towards me i'm gonna put you
right on the ground so we can get
something on your leg come towards me
you're okay i got you i got you
i got it
hold your hands on your back look at the
ground go to the ground go to the ground
come on
somebody get up